what's up man
hey guys how's it going we're doing good
how are you
i can't complain i'm just sitting back
watching jack it's gonna be hard to
follow that up
listen
everyone knows when the young wizard
comes on you got charts and you got good
news for us so uh let's get into the
charts first and then we'll get a little
college update too since uh uh we
haven't done that in a while but first
let's start with uh the utxo realized
price distribution or urpd um help us
understand we've been looking at this
for a while now and it seems like uh
we're getting kind of a continuation of
the existing trends when you look at
this there's several different um
clusters of volume essentially so you're
looking at different uh you know zones
of cost basis for market participants
and right now we're kind of sitting
right in between
the the cluster between 30k and 40k
and then also the cluster between like
43k and 50k
and so i'm looking for either you know
that previous cluster to you know serve
as support or the upper cluster to to
serve as kind of short-term resistance
overhead but i don't think we'll stay in
between for long
usually whenever we get between these
clusters it tends to gravitate one way
or the other
but that you know that 38 39k seems like
kind of a really strong line in the sand
there
got it and help people understand like
this realize price distribution
basically this is showing where people
bought their bitcoin and so when we're
below it it's unlikely that they're
going to be selling it because they'd be
selling at a loss and if we're above it
that they would actually be uh selling
at a profit is that kind of the way to
read
kind of like the this i'm also look at
it is if you have a zone of distribution
above you then that's going to serve as
resistance and then below support um and
so you want to get as much of the volume
below you as you can
because
there's you know just natural market
psychology as you move up the overhead
supply is is going to be sold to the
extent because people look to take
profits as uh prices move back up to
where their initial cost basis is so um
kind of i just see it as um areas for
for you know uh
where price is going to interact pretty
heavily especially like when we get up
to like the edge of one of these
clusters um that tends to be where you
know price has really heavy resistance
or we get to the bottom of those we see
pretty strong support
got it so let's also look at this net
realized profit loss chart that we have
uh in terms of uh we're back in kind of
the green here help us understand what
this is showing
us is just looking at
the net realized profit loss as it says
in the chart on every given day so you
look at all the profit and loss and
what's the you know what's the net
between the two what's the um
you know when you subtract the two what
you know what what state is the market
trading
and so what you get is from this week
earlier you know we had two consecutive
days of 650 million dollars of net
realized losses uh this is the first
back-to-back consecutive
pair of days that we had uh you know net
realized losses since like early july
so you know we had a significant little
sell-off that that the uh the market
absorbed
you know a lot of that was driven by
some some
de-risking behavior in traditional
markets and and we'll also get into our
soap for metric which is very similar
but you want to now see the market uh
hold a state of profit because that's
basically saying that people are selling
you know their coins from below and the
market's able to absorb that versus on
monday and tuesday we actually had
supply from that was you know
accumulated above where
price was currently that that we're
doing us
got it and then when we look at
something like the futures open interest
what are you seeing here
the big difference between
the sell-off or whatever two three weeks
ago and earlier this week
was you see you know earlier uh
that first off it was just a complete
drop off of features open interest and
that was because it was driven by a
liquidation cascade so you had you know
spiking open interest uh spiking funding
rates and then as you know a spot being
in the sell-off that kind of triggered
no stop losses and it has this cascading
effect on the market
and and so you'll see that just
completely dropped off and then for
sell-off this recent one it seems a bit
more controlled it just kind of seems
like risk-off behavior
from active managers and traders so i
think there's a you know
a little distinguishing between the two
uh that needs to kind of be acknowledged
there where um this wasn't necessarily
for selling it just seems like it was
you know correlation to traditional
markets you know we saw the s p so off
pixels we really heavily uh correlated
to the s p over the last month or two
so not surprising to see some some you
know de-risking in bitcoin as well got
it and then funding rates are negative
right now it looks like
and this is something you know we've
talked about for a long time uh this is
the mechanism that pegs the the curve
contracts to spot uh when you have
prolonged negative funding it's bullish
and you've uh prolonged positive funding
uh that's seen as a bearish thing
and so we kind of had these different
regimes when we were you know in the
summer in that little mini bear phase uh
had prolonged negative funding
and then over the last you know month or
month or two we've had pretty prolonged
positive funding including a spike
between as you mentioned at liquidation
cascade two or three weeks ago
but over the last week or so we've had
uh just straight negative funding so so
i want to see that continue because that
means
either age spots league futures or also
the futures market is is uh inaggregate
you know having strong demands uh to go
short so if you're gonna have a you know
you want to see the price rally while
traders continue to be disbelief and are
shorting that rally
got it and then sopra which is uh i feel
like you me and sober been hanging out
all summer long buddy uh to talk to me
about uh what you're seeing with sopra
this is the
net uh profit state of the market
essentially uh it's a ratio between all
the coins trading on a given day
and so what you're looking at is you
have this one line and that's your
neutral threshold below uh one is you're
trading you know in a state of loss
above in the state of profit and so in
bear markets this can be a good metric
to use to fade rallies where whenever
sober comes up and retests one that's a
good time to perhaps you know
hedge yourself or take some risk off the
table and then in
you know broader bull market trends uh
buying along these retests of one um is
have served to be you know good kind of
buy the dip opportunities
and so what you see is you know once
again during that summer regime um very
similar to funding meet negative we also
had sober below one uh came back to you
know retested uh one as support and then
since then we've been trading above that
one threshold uh but this week we
actually did below and recovered uh but
want to see now us
one that you want to now see is you know
come back down re-test that one as
support and then kind of stabilize above
one perhaps over the next week or two
you know we we've dipped below one
before and broader bull market trends
but what you don't want to see is us you
know come back below one and you know
and then retest it and then get rejected
that's that's what you would see so so
far i've reclaimed that state of profit
uh but now we're looking over the next
week or two to see if we can retest that
support and then also stabilize smoke
got it and one of the things that i
think you and i uh
have talked about in the past and you've
been doing a great job of is uh not just
reporting on and kind of covering or
analyzing existing metrics but you've
also been creating a number of new
metrics and one of those uh is this idea
of an illiquid supply floor so describe
what is the illiquid supply for like how
does it work and then tell us what
you're seeing in the chart
yeah this is something i created this
week with my uh my buddy matt he helped
me code because i can't code to save my
life
essentially what this is is it's plan b
stock to flow model but instead of using
circulating supply you're using a liquid
supply and so for anybody who's not
familiar
a liquid supply is defined a supply held
by entities who have very low spending
history so they take in a lot of coins
don't move many out and then uh liquid
supply is defined as entities who are
you know taking coins in but moving a
lot out
so those are like kind of the
speculators in the market and then
highly liquid is probably like market
pictures those kind of entities but
the liquid guys are really the
long-term you know investors the strong
hands that we we all like to
you know joke around about
and so essentially what this is trying
to do is create a floor based off of
bitcoin's uh real-time scarcity and so
you'll see like we have dipped briefly
below the model before like in mid 2017
very very briefly at the bottom of 2018
and also recently over summer we went
below but we never stayed below briefly
um and so although maybe you know this
model isn't perfect to the tick
you also see like after 2013 we came
back down and retested the floor there
it has served as a as a good proxy um
you know for perhaps where you know
long-term holders have set that price
for we also see like um last year after
september we we retested the floor and
bounced right off of it into the bull
market so i think you know with this
being you know with this being said the
floor currently sits at thirty eight
thousand three hundred um when we had
that correction uh last week we came
back down to like thirty thirty nine
thousand five hundred i believe so it
came pretty close to the floor um but
you know i think i think this is a good
uh area to to say you know
uh the the you know monster holders have
kind of set the floor here and it's a
good time to kind of average and
survives you know 38 39k is also a
pretty strong technical support level as
well as you know you see some bids set
down there um so like a little bit of um
confluence there but
yeah that that's that's essentially what
the model is trying to do is looking at
the behavior of these long-term
investors and trying to kind of estimate
where they kind of set the floor at yeah
it is fantastic so great work on that
one uh supply shock ratios we've been
talking a bunch about this uh and it
looks like we've got kind of this
bullish divergence that's playing out
here so what are you seeing on this
so we have three different metrics here
um the blue one which
um you know i
talk about this one all the time this is
the uh a liquid supply ratio uh
essentially this is just capturing the
movement of coins from those liquid
entities uh to the liquid entities so
movement of coins from from weak to
strong hands
bob can you still hear me because i lost
you on my screen i i can still hear you
um can you see me
i can't see you but it doesn't matter
it's all good just keep going buddy
because i'm just going through it on my
screen anyway uh the the red line is the
movement of coins from uh highly liquid
to liquidity so these are kind of the
intermediate term investors purple line
is the change supply shock ratio
movement of coins from well it's
essentially a ratio of uh the coins
available to be bond actually just that
to the amount of coins that aren't
available to be bond exchanges and so
right now as you mentioned we have this
kind of bullish divergence
and this is very similar to the the
divergence that we had in like june or
july i remember um you know very vividly
like being in hawaii and
me and me and really created this and i
did the episode i remember one week and
i was like in the hawaiian shirt when i
created the metric and this was back
when we were like you know
you know uh crypto twitter was just
completely you know desperate on and
like sentiment was garbage and i
remember we put this out and we were
saying yeah there's this divergence and
we're expecting some kind of supply
shock to play out people were like on
chain is opium this is all nonsense and
then we had 10 straight up days um and
it's interesting because that divergence
was a little bit larger in terms of like
how long it took to play out and it was
this kind of slow grind up whereas now
the metrics almost had this impulse up
while prices kind of had impulse down so
i find that interesting um just kind of
the the slope of the divergence is
different
um but yeah
going back it's it's hard to find any
times where where uh price hasn't you
know over time reacted to to the
underlying fundamentals although
sometimes it can take time to play out
as we saw in the summer um also like
this was a good leading indicator of the
drawdown before uh you know we moved out
in may i didn't have the metric at the
time but you know if i started to see
similar behavior where these metrics
started to decline pretty heavily then i
returned bearish but for now you know as
you see in the chart we just have this a
big impulse up while prices is moving
down so
you know expecting that to that
divergence to kind of play out in the
intermediate term um exchange flows have
looked uh slightly slightly bearish this
week you could say
4580
btc um in aggregate down to exchanges
about 190 million dollars a lot of these
inflows came to binance especially on
monday and tuesday when we had some of
that de-risking behavior
but you know when you zoom out it you
know you have these little you know down
draws but overall you know we've been in
an uptrend since since mid-july but you
know that changes then we'll be tracking
it so
what about whales it seems like whales
are just gobbling up every bitcoin they
possibly can find
so in this newsletter i tried to uh
focus on some of the more macro trends
and kind of zoom it out but
so i don't know the exact number that
they bought this week but you'll see you
know
whales in in a general sense buy into
these early parts of the rallies you
know obviously because they're the big
buyers so they pretty much are the ones
that are initiating the rallies um and
then they also begin to trim their
moldings into strength as retail steps
in so you'll see they bought really
heavily between the two 2013 double
pumps
they started buying into the bear market
after 2014 um started buying in you know
the bottom of 2018 moving into that
little mini 2019 uh bull run
also after covet or right around covid
they started buying heavily and then
they started selling you know
into the peak in the second half of 2013
into the strength in 2017 they sold the
top in 2019 they also sold the top in
earlier this year so following the you
know the behavior of whales has has been
a pretty decent strategy i would say um
and you know they've started buying
heavily since since mid july and you're
seeing that just continuing accumulation
from them and then retail it seems like
they also are getting in the game as
well
and this is once again you know very
very macro what you see is kind of in
the middle of these broader you know uh
uh bull run
2011 to 2013 double pumps
2017.
you see these large upticks in the
supply held by retail so
what i'm doing here is taking all the
entities less than 10 btc and then
dividing that by overall circulating
supply so you're getting the portion of
supply held by the little guys
essentially and we call these guys the
minnows um and and what you see is you
know since like mid to late feb or i'm
sorry mid to late may they've been
buying and kind of macro since you're
seeing that uptick that's similar to
previous cycles but it's not as the
slope isn't as steep um like if you look
at the chart you see these really steep
upticks so i find that interesting um
but yeah nonetheless you you're seeing
that same behavior that you see in the
middle of each cycle from from these uh
smaller guys
got it and then if we skip ahead to uh
looking at the hodl waves uh kind of
last chart that we have here how do you
think about um kind of
one what is the auto waves telling us
but then two like are there any
takeaways or implementations uh or
things that people can kind of say hey
the charts tell me this here's what i
should be doing
so they're basically showing you the um
by different age brackets so you have
from 24 hours day a week you know week
to month et cetera et cetera all the way
out to 10 years over 10 years um you're
looking at the amount of supply that
hasn't moved in each of those
denominated cohorts
so you can you know in a broader sense
we've talked about this many times
before
um what you see is that launcher motors
accumulate into weakness and accumulate
into the bear market um and and they
kind of lead us into the early phase of
the bull market
as you know short-term holders begin to
leave into these bearish phases of the
market and then they come step in and
push the price up and basically buy the
long-term holders bags the whole way up
into the bulldog
and so you see that in in shorts and
roller supply and lump to motor supply
but also here in the hollow waves um and
so what you see is like as we head into
the into the bear market you see that
the longer term guys take up a larger
portion of the spine move into the bull
run uh the the shorter term guys take up
a larger portion of supply right
and so right now um over over 93 percent
of supply hasn't moved in at least a
month which is an all-time high um and
so i just look at this as another way to
illustrate you know these broader supply
dynamics where this is going to have an
effect on prices the next week the next
two weeks but when we talk about what's
going to happen over the next couple
months you know you pair this with a lot
of the liquid supply data all these
different you know ways of measuring it
that we've been looking at you know talk
about the liquid supply rsi liquid
supply shock ratio i just created
another metric using moving averages of
a liquid supply um you know a lot of
these different things you look at
long-term holder supply reaching
all-time highs and also the liquid
supply is at all time highs
all these supply dynamics are pointing
to positive price action over the next
couple months and so yeah we may have
these short-term derivative led moves we
have these short-term you know uh mass
group of masco macro de-risking events
um that cause these short-term drawdowns
but when we talk about you know what
what is bitcoin's price gonna look like
in the next two three months you know
we're talking about late q4
into q1 i think you're going to see much
higher prices uh as jack said before i
before i hopped on um you know
you're seeing large you know large
buyers um you know you're talking about
whales
earlier and also these long-term guys
and then anecdotally you know like i i
thought for a while that a lot of the
talk about institutions was
uh perhaps you know stretching the truth
a bit you know i've been working at a
bitcoin company for almost two months
now i'm like i can just confirm
anecdotally that all that stuff is true
um and you see that in the data as well
right we're seeing like i said these
buyers so
you know i think we're gonna see much
higher prices over the coming months and
who the hell knows if we have these
short-term drawdowns you know i i don't
really care to be quite honest but i'll
be i'll be following the data to try to
help people be prepared to extend to my
newsletter but that's what i'm really
focused on is you know where is
bitcoin's price going to be at in
november december got it and when you
start to think about if we just zoom out
here it seems like one you're still very
bullish two there uh feels like there's
a bunch of uh large buyers that are
coming into the market many of them who
uh i'm assuming that you and i both know
uh that are uh unexpected um or much
bigger deals than people would uh would
think of and then on top of that all of
the on-chain metrics continue to suggest
that we're in this bull market and the
bull market is you know kind of just
getting uh started really uh to some
weird way not necessarily being near a
top or headed into a bear market
yeah i think some of these metrics
are pointing towards um the move out of
a bear phase into a into a bull market
um you know similar to coming out of the
bottom of 2018 um you know see some
similar patterns there
also you know coming out of the the
middle of the two 2013 double pumps
you know i think
when you're following these these
fundamental you know investor behaviors
you see you see these patterns right um
and you're starting to see the patterns
that resemble kind of the the early
phase of another uh major run-up um and
so to be quite to be quite frank i would
be surprised if we didn't see all-time
highs by the end of the year i mean i
think that's conservative though i'd be
surprised if we didn't see all-time
highs um you know by like mid to late
november to be quite honest so you think
that we'll see it you know here in the
next call it's six to ten weeks or so is
what you're thinking
maybe
conservative i would say indeed okay you
can be conservative so so and part of
this is like less about like people
should be trading on this information
it's more so like the data is what the
data is today and the data changes which
i think a lot of people don't realize
either we could go and three days from
now look at the data and it says
something completely different or
there's been changes whatever so it's
important to actually have an open mind
to be willing to change your mind as the
data changes correct
yeah for sure
one example is whenever i whenever i
show like um the liquid supply chart
like people always say oh well you know
a liquid supply is at the same level
that it was in april and it's like yes
but then it started going down and so
once it started going down you you would
turn bearish right i mean you just
follow what the data is telling you and
you know the data has just
continued to show stronger and stronger
trends um you know we've been
poppy and i have been tracking these
trends when you're talking about whales
uh any liquid supply long-term holders i
mean we've been tracking these things
since may and i think that's part of the
reason why people are like
well this stuff is all opium it's like
i'm just reading you the data right the
data the data is strong uh and you know
as long as these trends continue like my
outlook will stay the same data data
changes i'll i'll change you know my
outlook for the coming months but yeah i
think we're i think we're in a strong
spot here yeah i think that makes a ton
of sense to show you any questions uh
yeah well so this morning there was
obviously a pretty big sell-off uh
because of the china stuff what did you
see on chain this morning
think crazy i you know i saw some coins
being moved on to changes um especially
like some of the uh
it's hard to generalize these exchanges
and say they're certain like geographic
locations but you know like finance
i um some influence there which perhaps
represent you know like
eastern eastern virus or um i'm sorry
eastern sellers um
but it's not nothing like crazy i think
you know it's just another short-term
dry out i saw a bit of liquidations this
morning um nothing crazy it just seems
like you know the market
um overreacting a bit to news you know
we've seen you know china banned bitcoin
12 12 million times um i i don't think
that unless there's some news that i'm
missing i i don't see this as any
different than that um
any other questions john no it's good to
hear all-time highs coming soon
[Laughter]
i love it i love it all right well
what's going on with college uh are you
still uh enjoying it even though you're
not going to classes or what's uh what
what's up in uh in life
yeah man i'm having to hear um you know
almost two months ago now so i like all
the people that are you know having a
good time uh kind of having my own
schedule
and yeah you know having some fun of
course
it's it's funny you know like
this is a little off topic but you're
having all these young guys on like that
you know around you know college you
talk to dylan right and you know dylan
dylan's similar to me um you know he
dropped out way before me but he lives
around all his college buddies he's just
like getting all the benefits of
being in college and he's not even in
school and he just had jack on how old
it was jack like 26.7 or something like
that 27 i think
yeah okay so it's like you know boomers
watch out all the young guys are coming
you know
i think about this a lot in
15 or 20 years
even if you know which i think
just because of what's going on with
with macro like bitcoins has a really
strong set up for the next 10 years um
but you know even even if that's not the
case and
something unexpected happens like over
time the the zoomers are going to choose
to denominate in bitcoin and like over
time the boomers are going to retire
we're going to become the um
the predominant earners in the economy
and you know we choose to denominate in
bitcoin
and so i think you know that's a trend
that it's just not going to change
you're going to continue to see these
these older guys
um you know whether it's retire or
like not to be grim but you know as they
move into nursing homes and die off like
over time you know the younger guys are
going to come in and replace them and
you know we're very savvy with with you
know
technology and
we under you know understand this whole
concept of digital scarcity and so you
know bitcoin is just inevitable like you
know meeting all these other young guys
over the last couple months and
you see jack like
you know jack's like a big inspiration
just
what he's done especially he was in
bitcoin way before bitcoin was a big you
know i got into bitcoin in 2020 so
by then bitcoin was already a pretty
established asset you know jack got in
bitcoin years ago and you know seeing
what what he's really
done is is pretty inspiring for a lot of
the other young guys out there you know
i think a lot of us look at this and say
um
you know bitcoin is so new and
the the you look at the tan of bitcoin
and we're just where it is now simply
and
there's so much upside in that rather
than going into boomer finance and all
the edge has been extracted from the
market um you just get basically a
normal analyst like every other person
and you know you come into bitcoin and i
get to create new metrics and and
basically have like x-ray vision on the
market unlike anything that you have in
traditional finance i mean the
opportunities here whether you know
you're interested in analysis or you
want to build stuff i mean just look at
jack you know he just decided he wanted
to build something from his from his you
know closet
and you know he just he just got it
integrated with twitter so
um you know i i think for for a lot of
these younger guys you know just
hopefully people see
jack especially but also you know guys
like me and dylan and you know like if
if you're young out there and then you
want to get involved in bitcoin just go
go for it you know just just get
involved um just you know start putting
out content and
you know the community will
[Music]
and the bitcoin community cares about
how old you are what you look like i
mean we've got people with like anime
avatars that are like multi-millionaires
in the space i mean as long as you're
putting out like quality content on
twitter it'll get recognized and so i
don't know i just kind of wanted to to
use this to just
um encourage any any of the younger guys
out there to you know like go ahead and
get involved like don't be hesitant to
share your thoughts and
just get in there
i always tell people that the future is
created and built by young people right
it's not people who have their minds
hardened uh to the past or believe they
know the answers to everything it's
always built and uh and
created by young people so i think your
message is uh is dead on um all right so
we've got a whole bunch of uh stuff
we're gonna go over next week we're
gonna have you back on friday uh any uh
weekend plans you got
that's all you had to say no stop stop
you have fun stay safe don't do anything
i would do and uh we'll talk next friday
buddy
all right later what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're going to be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]